The time of year when spirits are high.
The holidays remind us of our hometowns and the loving embrace of parents.
Seollal is one of Korea's four biggest holidays.
It is celebrated on the first day of the lunar calendar.
Traditional dishes are prepared with dedication to pay respect to ancestors.
This is the most important New Year's Day ritual...
...as the entire family dresses in "hanbok", a traditional Korean clothing.
They kneel and bow for blessings.
Tteokguk, chapchae and gujeolpan are dishes enjoyed on Seollal.
Sebae is a traditional practice of paying respect to parents and grandparents after the charye.
As the children greet elders with deep traditional bows,...
...they wish each other prosperity and good fortune.
Tteokguk is commonly served during this holiday.
The white rice cakes symbolize a pure and fresh start for the New Year.
Koreans also say you age a year after having a bowl of tteokguk.
Yut Nori is a traditional family board game played with four wooden sticks called "yut."
It's a representative folk game enjoyed during Seollal as the family gathers in a circle.